[Music]
what's going on guys
we here at screen junkies were invited
to Legoland to sit down with the voice
cast of the new lego ninjago movie but I
thought it would be creepy for a grown
man me to walk around Legoland by
himself so we decided to send the
biggest kid we know and resident Lego
head
Jenny Nicholson to sit down with the
cast check it out
hi guys are you having fun today it's
been a good day so for me a lot of fun
yeah yeah because your Legoland and
there's so many things are becoming a
young kids I see you have a Lego with
you beautiful my first question I was
wondering if either of you guys have
actually constructed a Lego set I feel
like that implies that we got follow
rules and make what they want us to make
we don't do that we make what we want to
make there's an implication that we're
incapable but what we're deciding we're
like Basquiat
Picasso yeah is that what your LEGO
creations look like Picasso art there
are only about 20% better than because
yeah have you guys actually built LEGO
sets before a little bit a pirate ship
maybe a pirate ship might feel like you
just made that up
I might have as a kid the biggest one I
remember was there was a big pirate ship
oh I did Franco said pirate ship but he
sounded like he was lying I'm not lying
yes ference i said i would like a
question mark like he just thought me
too late a pirate ship he didn't play
Legos as much I didn't play Legos much
he was too busy brooding brooding so did
you play the lego video games as well at
all where they have those movie tie-ins
now I did not they've liked Lego
Jurassic world Lego Harry Potter Legos
are you thanks yeah pretend you knew
that like oh I'm familiar that's great
yeah I mean I don't call them video
games I call them life forces I caught
them experiences I haven't played oh no
I want to play the Lego admit that
I mean I've played video games I haven't
put the Lego I just pretend that you
play Blake okay yeah I'll play the Lego
games yeah amazing we did the lego
ninjago ride which is also a game and
Justin didn't win okay
that cowboy I feel like I'm getting like
really like what after that no on
this student no no I know what he's
doing is what's happened you're a scream
junkie what do you think would be like
the worst film to make into a lego movie
I'm gonna go with showgirls yeah Lego
Nightmare on Elm Street I would watch
that and then he could turn into all
these imaginative things going to make
this scare the children there been some
experimental movies in the 60s it were
just sound waves oh that would be great
and it could be Lego bricks doing that
yeah I forgot the name of the director
really well if he's still alive we could
get him to do the Lego into Darryl
Morris documentary Thin Blue Line
oh it would be a bad lego movie because
no one's gonna buy the documentary
credibility because they'll be like come
on that guy wasn't wrong
yeah like you could do Lego 127 hours
they'll be quite easy because you just
break the arm on that's what happens to
them and that happens if Franco and in
that movie it's his brother these
brothers are just losing arms in every
movie they do it's my dinner with Andre
like gee that'd be good Gigli like og
Lee would be great imagine lego
showgirls could be amazing look that's
what dave Franco said really like father
like son
dinner with Andre where it's just the
cover but you know set up really two
people said shoulder letters to people
said general because I'm thinking of
like the least active movie right just a
conversation an event like to to axe
that out with our
dinner was Andre yeah I've never seen
the morning
what do you mean how do you imagine this
okay great
please take the most accurate many
figures for the characters you're
representing from Lego no no is that
Freddy Krueger that is Freddy quatre
yeah what do you guys who's that is that
the victim of Freddy Krueger
with no face he's handsome not your
Andre okay and I'm having dinner with
you with a song oh my gosh no it's like
a chemistry set you think this guy is
willing a chemistry set guys do i want
to do i'm scarface scarface yes say
hello to my little friend and then watch
here's his little friend
oh you planned that I just improvised
that I don't remember any lines from
similar lines
oh no you don't hear about when the guy
says it's a thin blue line or thing he
just said the things separating good
from evil
is it a memorable a look we're all here
because we love you and your drug use as
if I did our life in the following ways
oh my god this is Scarface interventions
an intervention it's great this is what
the film needed I can handle it
you know if you don't hear that you
don't go to rehab you will no longer pay
for your bills I can phone on you can no
longer stay in my home you're the one
good or mom but I'm gonna cut off your
cell phone bill it's the 1780s there's
no cell phones yet we keep
that film No so um 2019 I don't be the
baby there he's made us improvise um I
don't think that that's Julie can we
just keep her you guys he just don't let
her I need you to can you tell I'm
attached this year I can go so we just
get I know where to find you
well that was a good time so what would
be the most inappropriate movie to give
the lego treatment to let us know what
would be cringe-worthy and weird in the
comments below
we want to know once again I want to
thank my friend Jenny Nicholson and the
folks with lego ninjago see it opening
September 22nd I want to thank you for
watching I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on
Twitter bye